in true boys fashion if you make the
right choice you get rewarded and if you
make the wrong choice you get punished
and butcher has a tendency of like nine
times out of ten he will make the wrong
choice
the boys
who the hell are you how do you know
that her name's butcher
Billy butcher you're the Fantastic thing
about working on the boys it's a very
collaborative process if you come up
with an idea that you know has some
Merit you pitch it to Kripke you know
he's fantastic he plays best idea wins
when we were shooting the first season
and there's a scene where butcher is
trying to convince Huey to go into vote
and plant a listening device then go
back into the boardroom sit down big
smiles plant the bug underneath the
table easy peasy japanesey Bob's your
uncle that's sick
that's that to me it seemed very like
the threshold of the rabbit going down
the rabbit hole in Alice in Wonderland
and also reminded me a bit of the Matrix
with that in mind I pitched Kripke in
the idea that that butcher would
reference The Matrix and it's like this
is this moment and then we shot that and
that's the one that they ended up using
I stuffed it up but the story I got the
pills confused which was an absolute
accident in the moment it just ended up
being comedy genius which is it's very
butchered growing into your chai tea
green latte what the [ __ ] or you could
take the blue pill
was it the red pill anyway take the
other pill and equipping which pill do
you want me to take just quit being
that's what I'm saying I think as far as
butcher's relationship with Huey goes
the sort of underlying connection
between the two you know butcher is on a
on a Path of Revenge you know the
incorrect path to be on Huey was really
on the on the path for justice for what
happened to Robin and and that's
obviously the correct part you know in
true boys fashion if you make the right
choice you get rewarded and if you make
the wrong choice you get punished and
butcher has a tendency of like nine
times out of ten he will make the wrong
choice
[Music]
foreign
the whale is probably one of the most
crazy scenes that I've ever shot in my
career to tell you the truth that was me
actually driving the speed boat and the
day that we picked was actually a pretty
stormy day and so you know when I was
going at the considerable amount of
speed and I was like actually getting
air off the waves poor Jack Quaid is I
think never been in a speed boat let
alone a speedboat that's you know
jumping waves and flying through the air
and and he was freaked out he had a
safety word which was Carl and he's
sitting up at the front of the boat and
he's not facing me apparently he's
screaming at the top of his lungs he's
like oh God
I didn't hear him but we ended at the
run and this poor kid was white as a
sheep and I thought it was just that he
was seasick or something but he was he
was terrified we ended up swapping him
out we had somebody else come and put
Huey's clothes on and this guy loved it
he was having a ball and the whale
itself was an actual
gigantic sort of 60-foot whale they
built it on a beach and we had a boat on
a track which we slammed into that and
it was a fully interior exterior set
where they had organs still pumping
inside I mean it was gross we were
covered in blood but a lot of fun well I
think where we find butcher at the
beginning of season three he's in a
state where he hasn't processed the
death of Becker at all he is struggling
to be some kind of paternal figure to
Ryan which he dearly wants to be and and
to honor his promise to Becca to protect
him but you know that task is completely
at odds with butcher's fundamental core
Mission which is to get revenge on
homelander and so obviously something's
got to give and really the season is
about how far are you willing to go are
you willing to turn yourself into a
monster in order to defeat that monster
and obviously in butcher's case he's
like yeah sure why not
still a thing eh it's my thing I founded
it in 52.
me and this other soup Liberty man was
she a firecracker
butcher really comes in at the end of it
so I didn't get the full um brunt of the
harrogasm experience Jensen tells this
great story where he's walking on set
one day and he sees one of the cameramen
on a box eating a sandwich and he goes
hey how's it going and the cameraman
looks up to them with his thousand yard
steer and goes dude I've seen some [ __ ]
I really felt for the crew because they
uh they they really got put through it
on that one and just like hearing the
first A.D give directions to the extras
okay can you please put your hand on his
yeah and then can you put her your I
mean it was just like what are we
shooting here it was wild it was it was
a lot of fun Star Trek
[Music]
koi Leonard McCoy
well you know there was certainly points
there where I definitely felt the weight
and responsibility of getting it right
stepping into
such an iconic character that was played
so wonderfully well by the late great to
Forrest Kelly and really a beloved
character JJ was very adamant that we
should go in there and make these
characters our own to some extent I did
but I also felt like as a long-term fan
of Star Trek that it was important to
see some sort of recognizability
particularly in the character of bones
for me it was really about sort of
cherry picking some of the essence of
what DeForest Kelly did and sort of
imbuing it into the character without
sort of slipping into some kind of
imitation which wouldn't have been a
good move
Shields at 60 I understand or should we
I don't know fire back
no
of course
and it was fun and again you know JJ is
also a wonderfully collaborative
director and we were all very blessed to
be in a situation where he was open to
collaborating to work with you and to to
help build those characters such
technology could theoretically be
manipulated to create a tunnel through
space-time damn it man I'm a doctor not
a physicist are you actually suggesting
that from the future you eliminate the
impossible whatever remains however
improbable must be the truth how poetic
it's just great to be able to get
together every now and then and make one
of those movies and it's the best hang
you don't stop laughing you know from
Simon Pegg to Chris Pine and John Cho
they're incredibly funny guys I mean
you're literally in hysterics all day
long and the last one was the best you
know sadly it was after that that we
lost Anton tragically and that really
hurt you know was uh such an amazing guy
so intelligent and so had such a massive
future ahead of him he was going to get
into directing an extraordinary actor as
well very well respected it and for us
to to lose him was a real tragedy but
that summer where we shot Star Trek
Beyond was probably my favorite Star
Trek movie that we shot you know we were
up in Vancouver and we were tight it was
good fun good thing to worry princess
[Music]
I had done a bunch of stuff in New
Zealand and then Rob tapart who's an
amazing producer brought a show to New
Zealand called Hercules and off that was
spun off Xena Warrior Princess which was
Lucy lawless's uh show and that was an
incredible experience for a multitude of
reasons it was the first time that a
show of that production value had really
been shot in New Zealand
and it really upskilled everybody not
only just actors but also the crew and
in actual fact many of the crew were
then cherry-picked by Peter Jackson and
they went on to work on Lord of the
Rings Nyla Dickinson who did the
Wardrobe for those shows went on to win
an Oscar as did Richard Taylor and
wetter so you know that show was really
vital for the New Zealand film industry
uh in a lot of ways and was an
incredible learning experience for all
of us you know I really always enjoy
playing the villains interesting
Roman design
I can't believe you would double cross
me just as I was about to double cross
you
characters that uh you have one just so
driven and uh so focused and you know
you have a lot of fun playing them as
you can see you know so for me yeah I
mean it's like anytime I have an
opportunity to play a villain on that
show was was a good day
having the opportunity to work with Lucy
Lawless and to see how a number one
drives the ship uh wasn't a valuable
inspirational experience she's got a
ride on the clock and she's like all
right come on lots to do and she's just
sort of gently getting everybody to you
know when the crew gets tired to sort of
focus and sort of drive forward and I
still think of her even today when I'm
shooting the boys and the example that
she set it's an amazing woman Lord of
the Rings
[Music]
what business there's an elf a man and a
dwarf having the Ridder mark
speak quickly
give me your name horse master I had
done a small New Zealand film called the
price of milk and the director of that
was very good friends with Peter Jackson
and he took a rough cut of the price of
milk down to show Peter and I heard it
just happened to be in in Peter's face
when he was looking for someone to to
cast in the role of of AMA we kind of
get this call out of the blue inviting
me to to come down and play with them
and uh I was absolutely elated this was
like a dream come true sadden King
stands alone
not alone
[Music]
the battle scenes in Lord of the Rings I
mean were pretty insane sure there's a
certain amount that was generated or a
lot that was generated
on a computer but they also went to such
Extreme Measures to put some serious
numbers on the field and I remember when
we were shooting uh I think this is one
of the charges of minister they put out
a call in the South Island to all
able-bodied horse riders to bring your
horse to you know this location on this
day and hundreds and hundreds of people
turned up a lot of women turned up and
they slapped beards on them and and put
them in these fantastic costumes and we
had a significant like hundreds of
riders there charging you know down the
field and the sound of it I never forget
the sound and the you know the Earth was
literally shaking I mean I saw more of
my country shooting that over the three
years than I had living there my entire
life the friendships that were formed in
that were you know really endured you
felt like you went through something
Peter Jackson is
is such a genius he's literally like
working with an Einstein of of film his
knowledge is
so impressive just to be in the company
of such incredibly talented people right
throughout the production and if you
just look at that cast like Sevilla
Mortensen and Ian McKellen uh Bernard
Hill Christopher Lee Brad duruff I mean
these guys are incredible and I remember
taking any opportunity I could to
actually watch these guys work and I
remember watching you know Vigo for
example and just seeing the way that he
would subtly put the emphasis in
different places every single take that
was a really huge lesson for me that he
he had the the confidence and not only
him himself but then also the process
the director the editor to to do that
honestly it was uh one of the most
amazing experiences of my life
[Music]
I didn't read
many Comics at all in fact you know
pretty much dread was the only one but I
really responded to the world of dread
the character the dark sort of satirical
look at this dystopian future and also
the character who could be
heroic at times but he could also be a
villain and you know as a representative
of a very
sort of right-wing regime establishment
it's set in a time where politicians
have been dispensed with and the judges
have literally taken power and are now
patrolling the streets dispensing on the
spot Justice and it's a ruthless kind of
Justice working with Alex Garland who
was the writer and pretty much the the
director of the whole project was an
invaluable experience most of dread was
shot at Cape Town film studios we did a
little bit exterior work in a couple of
locations driving the lawmaster
motorbike that was a lot of fun but yeah
so for the most part it was all in the
studio and I remember you know a lot of
practical effects there were a lot of
explosions and we were firing you know
weapons that were actually real weapons
that had a casing built around it to
make them look like futuristic lawmaster
weapons but yeah it was it was a lot of
fun I'd actually met Leno years ago on
the set of born Supremacy I remember we
were shooting some pickups in London and
scene where dread comes in at the end
and they sort of face each other and I
come on set and I'm wearing the dread
helmet and she's standing far into the
set and she just she looks at me and
just starts maniacally laughing let's
just say it added good motivation to the
scene I mean she was crazy she was
brilliant in the film do you know how
many people live in this block
this isn't a negotiation
sentence is death
can't afford to take the risk
and you know I certainly would be
interested to revisit the character
there's just such a great depth of
material there that was written by John
Wagner and various writers over the
years particularly stories of revolving
around judge death and a lot of great
stories to me it doesn't bother me if
like I get the opportunity to play dread
again or it's someone else I would just
love to see those stories I mean I'd be
excited for for anybody who gets their
hands on the rights to do that that'd be
incredible for Ragnarok behold
[Applause]
my stuff
I'm particularly fond of these I pulled
them out of a place on midgard called
Texas I you know really just got a call
from Tiger out of the blue saying hey do
you want to come and play I've got this
really cool roll of scourge you'd be
working with Kate Blanchett I'm like
sign me up I don't need to read anything
I'll stop you there what I meant was
what's your ambition
I just wanna
chance to prove myself it was fantastic
you know I mean you remember turning up
to work one day on set and there's Sam
Neal Anthony Hopkins and just sitting
around and that to me is probably one of
my favorite days when you're sitting
around with Tony Hopkins and and Sam
Neil shooting the shirt Sam Neal was
probably
one of the actors that had really
inspired me to be an actor coming from
New Zealand getting an international
career and same with uh with Anthony
Hopkins and the thing that I loved about
working with Tyco is that the take
wasn't sacrilegious like you'd be in the
middle of a take doing a dialogue and
he'll come and go hey why don't you try
and say this or that or why don't you
come pick up there to do that you know
and it was really kind of liberating in
a way because there was nothing precious
about it and it just became like um a
lot more free-flowing a lot more
improvisational for us God foreign
that didn't make the final cut because
the character has a really wonderful Arc
that um first of all out of
self-preservation he aligns himself with
with hella because he could see that if
he doesn't he's gonna be killed but then
you know through the course of the film
he gets more and more sickened by what
he's required to do in in order to you
know hold that decision up to work for
her and there was a scene where he uh
chops the head off this young girl in a
town square because hella asks him to
and then post that scene there's a scene
which which didn't make the final cut is
he is
absolutely second to the core we find
them in some corner and he's actually
being physically sick by what he's done
and that was really sort of the Genesis
for this this turn that he takes and
this the guilt that he feels about what
he's done and how he's going to at the
right point in time make it right and
and that's always fun when you when you
have a character that you can take him
in One Direction and then you know have
a pivot I always if I can find the
opportunity to do that I will that's one
of the things I look for in a role and
another one is to make sure that the
character has a real utility a real
function like if you can tell the story
without your character then that's not
something that you want to do if the
character serves no utility no purpose
no function don't do the roll
out of the blue
[Music]
ran into a
friend of mine and she said oh you know
my husband's producing this movie and
I remember it and the movie was about a
small town massacre in the south island
and I'm gonna say 19 early 1990s and I
think it was tragically about 12 or 13
people were shot and that we'd never
experienced anything like that before
Psychopathic gunman went loose and I
remembered that vividly I remember as it
unfolded and and I sort of thought well
that that might be something that I'd be
interested in being a part of and so I
met with the director and I read the
script and I sort of took on the role of
this small town cop who's sort of really
struggling to deal with the tragedy as
it unfolds
the situation was completely different
in those days you know if you're to take
down an armed Defender you actually had
to radio back to your base to say I have
a shot can I take the shot you know
there was no uh SWAT team no armed
Defender Squad you know that incidence
was really the birth in New Zealand of
that element of the police sort of an
important historical sort of point in in
New Zealand particularly for the New
Zealand you know communities
after this
probably
the heaviest film that I've ever worked
on and when I finished it I thought that
I didn't want to make anything like that
ever again the people who were there and
involved and the community that we were
shooting in we were shooting one Bay
over from when it happened they didn't
want us there they don't just wanted to
let that story rest I was grateful to uh
to have been a part of it and you know
again like there's some incredibly
talented people involved in that Greg
Fraser the DP has gone on he's now
working with Denny villanue on the June
movies it was a heavy but an amazing
experience
Supremacy
he's my friend there's been a death in
the family and I wonder if you've seen
him
well I had seen the first born movie I
remember being in a in a movie theater
in New Zealand going to the first one
and going man that's exactly the kind of
film that I'd love to do I had just done
a couple of films for Universal and off
the back of that they offered me the
role of Corel the Assassin and in born
and I just I was like I'm off I'm going
to do it
foreign
that character was uh pretty cold he was
just working on the other side but it's
you know a lot of people say oh who's
the bad guy but yes yeah he was but from
my perspective I wasn't playing him like
that I was playing him as a guy who was
following his orders it's just no
emotion he's just doing a job nothing
personal
Moscow car chase we shot up each portion
of it and Russia we shot some of it in
Berlin but the Russian stuff was
incredible the production had to pay the
local cops to shut off the roads so we
could shoot it for whatever reason we
didn't get the perm to shoot so we were
going around Moscow literally stealing
shots we'd have one cop on a bike and he
would literally walk out into the street
hold his hand up stop the traffic and go
okay go and I'm in a in a seven Series
BMW and it's like and I'm flooring it
really sort of cowboy sort of stuff but
that's how we were getting the shots
and then they trained me out to do a
reverse 180 in a Mercedes G-Wagon and
that was that was a lot of fun and then
actually let me do it if you watch the
movie there's a camera station behind me
in the G-Wagon as I spin the wheel going
in reverse you'll just see the
background just go sideways and that's
that's not CGI that's actually they let
me do it I can never look at a Mercedes
G-Wagon the same way